Christmas time Christmas time it is
Christmas time what's up everybody this
is every damn day and as you can see by
all this stuff that's eventually going
to wind up in the ocean it's Christmas
[Music]
folks I love Christmas
I love the traditions the family the
food the paid time off I've even taken
my dog to see Santa Claus but we need to
make some changes it's too predictable
every year Christmas is exactly the same
same song same family same food I've had
enough it's time to give Christmas a
reboot every year I tried to find the
perfect present for everyone that I know
then I checked the prices and settle for
making something homemade for my
girlfriend the best presents come with
an apology let's be real there is no
greater gift and then a card with money
in it that's all we want let's stop
beating around the bush and become the
aunts and uncles that we know we are
deep down inside my grandpa only signed
three cards in his entire life he would
give us the card we'd take the money out
and give him the card right back so he
could give it to us the next Christmas
that's how gift-giving should work
gift-giving is an attack on good people
finding a perfect gift is impossible
[Music]
Hey Merry Christmas got you a little
something I got you the boots you wanted
by selling my computer I love them what
what's wrong I thought you really wanted
those boots it did but oh no did you you
gave me something from my computer just
open it what's in the box
just open it what's you can buy just
open it this is a severed human foot
it's my foot what why would you do this
I love you you love me about what and
you saw you severed your foot because
you'd love mine this is not the Gift of
the Magi have you even read that story
ah those crazy kids I'm a Catholic which
means that every Christmas Eve I go to
midnight mass it's a big moment for me
because like every good Catholic
Christmas marks the second time of year
that I actually go inside a church
midnight mass is great because it brings
people together mostly to share a moment
of panic when they realize that there's
a second verse - oh come all ye faithful
but hey it's late and we're all mumbling
anyway church needs an update I'm so
tired of the same Christmas stories
every year we go to church we hear the
same stuff tell me about something
different you keep telling me about the
birth of baby Jesus in the first
Christmas I'm tired of the first
Christmas tell me about the second
Christmas they got a one year old
they're still sleeping in a barn
everyone's upset she paid all the
garland or I don't know the ninth
Christmas tell me about that right they
got to sit Jesus down tell them Santa
Claus isn't real well why do we do any
of this it's your birthday or tell me
about the 16th Christmas where they have
to tell Jesus where babies come from
well not you you were different
we need new stories and don't look for
Hollywood to help us they've been
shoveling the same crap down our throats
for years
[Music]
sure the Santa Claus it's a family
comedy about becoming Santa Claus but
isn't it really a movie about how easy
it is to murder the elderly and assume
their identity right this is not to get
to the Magi have you even read that
story the holidays also marked that time
of year where you get together with your
family to rehash all the arguments you
had over Thanksgiving it's stressful to
see your family the same movies are on
TV
and somehow no matter what time it is
it's always at least an hour until the
food's ready we all love our families
and that's why we can't stand them you
know you're more likely to be murdered
by a loved one and the same goes for the
people that you love that's why this
year I'm introducing a new tradition I
call it the family hour hello sharks the
family hour is a whole hour where
everyone spends time together separately
it's an hour where everyone leaves
everyone else alone we get to look at
our phones maybe stare at a wall or do
like my dad does and get lost in the
garage for some unknown reason everyone
wins
but just for an hour as soon as the hour
is up everyone has to put their phones
down do what my mom asks and quote come
back to the living room and act like
you're a part of the family
let me know what you're gonna do with
your family and the comments Merry
Christmas enjoy the holidays and make
sure to check out our other show on the
Comedy Central Twitter extra damn day
[Music]
you